12 liegen wir einen gigantischen
physikalischen irrtum auf demnach wäre
eine vollkommen neue physik nötig um die
größe des universums zu bestimmen denn
die variiert je nach größe der hubble
konstante denn die ist sie nach
messungen gar nicht konstant und
kosmologen und kosmologen aus den usa
sorgen jetzt für gewaltigen aufruhr wie
das forschungsteam auf die these kommt
die alle so schmalz kriegs um
science-fiction gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonnierten
kann dann nur dann und nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
astronomie teams konnten mit ihren
teleskopen bisher nicht anfangen das
sich aus fernsten galaxien vor rund 13
milliarden jahre zu uns auf den weg
gemacht hat können wir deswegen also
davon ausgehen dass der durchmesser des
kosmos also 26 milliarden lichtjahre
groß ist wenn wir davon ausgehen dass
sein land in jeder richtung etwa 13
milliarden lichtjahre entfernt ist wäre
dies die schlussfolgerung
doch diese rechnung ist dann doch etwas
zu einfach schließlich dehnt sich der
kosmos aus auch währenddessen das licht
der fernen galaxien durch ihn hindurch
läuft und wer weiß vielleicht dehnt er
sich ja am rand schneller als mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit aus das licht würde
uns nie erreichen und so müssen
forschungsteams weltweit zahlreiche
faktoren in ihre berechnungen
einbeziehen wenn sie sich zu den
ausmaßen unseres universums gedanken
machen beispielsweise die
zusammensetzung der materie die raum
krümmung und die geschwindigkeit der
ausdehnung des kosmos einige schätzungen
kommen dann auf einen durchmesser des
kosmos von bis zu 100 milliarden
lichtjahren in vielen berechnungen in
diesem zusammenhang spielt die
sogenannte hubble konstante eine
wichtige rolle der astronomen edwin
hubble beobachtet schon 1928 dass sich
andere galaxien von uns weg bewegen und
zwar umso schneller je weiter sie von
uns entfernt sind der rückschluss daraus
ist dass es das weltall selbst ist dass
sich ausdehnt das humble gesetz
beschreibt vereinfacht gesagt wie
schnell die geschwindigkeit der galaxien
mit ihrer entfernung wächst sie bildet
quasi die basis für unser modernes
verständnis von unserem kosten
doch jetzt kommt das große aber denn
nicht alle methoden zur messung der
hubble konstante führen zum selben
ergebnis studien zeigen dass der wert
ein anderer ist wenn man uralte
schallwellen genauer analysiert bzw
wenn man das licht von entfernten
galaxien näher betrachtet mal liegt die
hubble konstante bei 67 oder 68 mal bei
73,2 in manchem rechnungen erhält man
auch ein ergebnis das irgendwo
dazwischen liegt die messung sind anders
als andere naturkonstanten einfach super
aufwendig schließlich basieren sie auf
der entfernung anderer astronomische
objekte und ihrer geschwindigkeit im
bezug auf und sind dabei handelt ist
sich jedem um wirklich sehr weit
entfernte astronomische objekte heißt
also im klartext genau genommen ist die
hubble konstante anders als ihr name
andeutet gar nicht konstant und das
raubt forschungsteams weltweit den
schlaf denn was bedeuten diese
unstimmigkeiten heißt das etwa dass den
beteiligten forschungsteams bisher nicht
sauber gearbeitet haben nein sagt jetzt
eine neue studie demnach liegt der
fehler nicht bei den kollegen und
kolleginnen aus der wissenschaft sondern
beim universum selbst dazu einer der
beteiligten autoren lloyd knox in den
letzten zwei jahren habe ich meine
annahme dass sie etwas falsch gemacht
haben könnten korrigiert stattdessen
denke ich vielleicht haben sie nichts
falsch gemacht vielleicht ist das
stattdessen der hinweis auf den ich
gewartet habe
knox und sein team sind überzeugt davon
dass wir eine neue physik brauchen damit
schließlich alle messergebnisse zur
hubble konstante übereinstimmen unser
bisheriges physikalisches verständnis
und die darauf basierenden modelle seien
einfach noch nicht ausreichend somit
könnten alle messungen zur größe des
universums stimmen die interpretation
dieser messungen dagegen nicht dabei
gegen knox und co ihren fokus auf das
modell des sogenannten klang horizont
diese betrachtung macht es kosmologie
teams möglichst das frühe universum zu
untersuchen demnach haben schallwellen
die beim urknall durch das vermischen
von licht und materie entstanden sind
das universum zum klingen gebracht nach
dem abkühlen der materie nach etwa
380.000 jahren stoppte das klingen denn
die schallwellen wurden abgedämpft doch
darf man blieb etwas übrig und zwar ein
eingefrorenes wellen
im kosmischen mikrowellenhintergrund und
der klang beziehungsweise schall
horizont definiert die letzten
schallwellen des musters und das us
forschungsteam ist sich sicher dass
diese aufgenommenen klänge konkrete
ableitung zu den eigenschaften und
zusammensetzung des universums möglich
macht doch dabei sei das bisherige
modell des klang horizont zu korrigieren
laut knox würden tatsächlich alle
studien stimmig sein wenn man die größe
des klang horizonts verkleinern würde
eine erklärung könnte sein dass das sehr
junge universum deutlich schneller
expandiert ist als wir es bisher
annehmen dann wäre es vereinfacht gesagt
auch schneller abgekühlt und der klang
horizont wäre früher eingefroren und
somit auch kleiner als in den bisherigen
modellen angenommen bei diesem ganzen
überlegungen sind die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
ziemlich optimistisch einem noch
verborgenen geheimnis unseres universums
auf die spur zu kommen möglicherweise
sogar zu einer art neuen zutat im
dunklen sektor die loxxess formuliert
demnach gibt es möglicherweise eine art
dunklen turbo der die expansion des
universums beschleunigt hat oder aber
die mysteriöse dunkle energie hat mehr
als nur eine form und kann sich im lauf
der zeit verändern so eine weitere
spekulation des forschungsteams darüber
hat der ja berichtet was ja eine ein
erstes indiz für die stringtheorie wäre
wenn die dunkle energie sich im wert
verändern würde
und so sollen teleskope den klang
horizont weiter untersuchen dadurch soll
dann hoffentlich zeitnah der ware hubble
wert bestimmt werden und dies zeigt dann
auch ob die forschungsteams bislang
unsauber gearbeitet haben oder ob
tatsächlich eine art neue physik
notwendig ist dazu wenn die freeman von
der university of chicago
es wird natürlich viel interessanter
wenn sich herausstellt dass es sich
dabei um einen grundlegenden physik
handelt doch die entscheidung darüber
liegt natürlich nicht bei uns dem
universum ist es egal was wir denken
ganz andere these das universum ist ein
schwarzes loch dafür hier klicken
anschauen und raumzeit block der zukunft
abonnieren bislang bleibt dran